hey what's up guys
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for today july 20th
2021 uh do me a favor subscribe to our
youtube channel
tap the notification bell share our
videos
and all that good stuff only three
stories for you today we're mixing it up
a little of everything
uh first off there is this incredible
really incredible
compilation video of democrats over the
past
couple years complaining about voter
hacking and voting machines not working
and election integrity problems and all
that sort of stuff of course
it's all pre this election now we're not
allowed to talk about that
there is a good chance i will be booted
off youtube or at least get a strike for
doing this video today
if so please join us at
rubenreport.locals.com because we are
going to show you
this compilation video these are all
public officials making statements of
their own volition
so uh youtube uh gods that are watching
this right now
please don't shut us down these are
democrats saying these things i know
these are things you were allowed to say
before this election
you're not allowed to say anymore we're
just gonna play them and
let their words stand on their own uh
part two this is breaking right now
there is
a hearing in washington dc a more
wretched hive of skull
scum and villainy you will not find uh
but rand paul senator rand paul from
kentucky who obviously is uh one of the
few politicians
that i think is a pretty decent guy son
of uh
ron paul of course and really the only i
would say true
libertarian senator i would say ted cruz
is kind of close but rand paul i would
say is probably
mostly in line with the types of views
that i espouse on this show
he really got into it with dr anthony
fauci today the infallible fouchy
over this gain of function research that
was happening in the wuhan lab i'm going
to explain what gain of function is
we're going to show you about a three
minute clip of them going back and forth
basically calling each other liars and
i'll try to unpack it in a sensible way
i think it's important to show you this
three-minute clip because we need some
context here because basically rand paul
is saying
that we through grants funded the
research
at wuhan lab which then use gain of
function research
which basically takes uh animal disease
and
and uh manipulates it in essence so that
it can be
uh spread to humans uh and that we sort
of funded this whole thing and that
fauci has something to do with that
you'll see how fauchi kind of bounces
around and
sort of you'll see his very technical
bureaucratic way of speaking
but he doesn't completely deny the gain
of function thing which is sort of
interesting because he was
pretty much denying it a few weeks ago
and then finally
we're going to talk a little bit about
cuba and socialism and of course that
will involve
aoc and the 1619 project and everything
else
which it's sort of nice what's happening
right now the democrats are doing
exactly
what i said they would do i mean i
started saying this a couple of years
ago when
when bernie and the crew when they were
saying they're democratic
socialists right we're democrat
socialists and i kept saying to
everybody well they're going to drop
democrats soon enough
and isn't it interesting you don't hear
them say it anymore right
they say they're progressives but they
don't really say they're democrats and
they don't really
say that they're full socialists but
that's it's pretty much coming
and we've got some audio and some tweets
to prove it guys before i get to any of
that i want to talk to you about bonner
private wine i've got some mile back
right here
here's a tip for you next time you grill
up a couple of steaks pop open a bottle
of extreme
altitude malbec wine it comes from these
remote vineyards in argentina located
up at around 9000 feet when these
vintners aren't making wine they're
herding cattle so they know meat
they know barbecue and that's what these
malbecs are for as soon as you open the
bottle you're going to experience
delicious notes of blackberry leather
smoke and a little dark cherry
you're also getting less sugar less
chemicals and additives and
ten times more resveratrol which is a
powerful longevity booster we're
actually busting out
a uh rib eye tonight i will be putting
pictures at the report.locals.com
and i will be drinking some extreme al
malbec wine
the guys over at freethinkerwine.com
just got a special shipment of these
wines in they've got one malbec from the
third highest vineyard in the world
at almost 9 000 feet visit
freethinkerwine.com today and you'll get
50
off the line and 50 off shipping this is
a small batch and it's going to go fast
just visit freethinkerwine.com
that's freethinkerwine.com and now back
to me all right let's just get right
into the stories so
first this incredible compilation
video has been making its way around the
twitter and i hope
that you good people are trying to stay
sane through all this madness and you're
not spending too much time on twitter so
we thought we'd show it to you
we got a whole bunch of democrats circa
2018
basically saying everything about voter
fraud and voter
machines and error and manipulation and
everything else
pretty much everything that mike lindell
the pillow guy you know mr pillow he's
always hugging a pillow loves donald
trump
pretty much everything he's been saying
about this past election well that's
pretty much what they were all saying
when it came to talking about what might
have happened in 2016 and what they're
going to have to do going forward
take a look-see i continue to think that
our voting machines are too vulnerable
for researchers have repeatedly
demonstrated that ballot recording
machines and other voting systems
are susceptible to tempering even
hackers with limited prior knowledge
tools and resources
are able to breach voting machines in a
matter of minutes in 2018
electronic voting machines in georgia
and texas deleted votes for certain
candidates
or switch votes from one candidate to
another the biggest seller of voting
machines
is doing something that violates cyber
security 101
directing that you install remote access
software which would make a machine like
that
you know a magnet for fraudsters and
hackers these voting machines
can be hacked quite easily you could
easily hack into them
it makes it seem like all these states
are doing
different things but in fact three
companies are controlling this it is the
individual voting machines
that some pose that pose some of the
greatest risks there are a lot of states
that are dealing with antiquated
machines right which are vulnerable to
being hacked
workers were able to easily hack into an
electronic voting machine it was
possible to switch votes
43 percent of american voters
use voting machines that researchers
have found
have serious security flaws including
back doors we know how vulnerable now
our systems were we know
i know the hackathon that took place
last year where virtually every machine
was broken into fairly quickly i
actually held a demonstration for my
colleagues
here at the capitol where we brought in
folks who before our eyes hacked
election
machines those that are not those that
are being used in many states
aging systems also frequently rely on
unsupported software
like windows xp and 2000 which may not
receive regular security patches
and are thus more vulnerable to the
latest methods of cyber attack
in a close present or election they just
need to hack one swing state or maybe
one or two
or maybe just a few counties in one
swing state
i'm very concerned that you could have a
hack that finally went through
oh mama mia all right so just to be
clear
if you were to say any of the things
that
all of those democrats and those are not
random democrats right like
this video is not of just like democrats
you ain't never heard of this
this video is of ted liu this video is
amy klobuchar
this video is kamala harris like these
are mainstream democrats okay people
that are
they're good people they're better
people than we are right because i know
you're a right-wing maniac just like i
am
uh if you were to say any of the things
that they were saying back
in 2018 or basically before the 2020
election if i was to say any of those
things right now
related to the 2020 election my channel
would be deleted like we'd get a strike
we'd get a second strike and
strike and we'd just be blown away but
not only that if you were to say any of
those things
in your circles in your social circles i
wonder what your friends would say they
would say you're a conspiracy theorist
you've been watching too much
alex jones or something like that
and that's why this is all deeply
dangerous the very
same things that people were saying over
the last couple months
like oh could things have been hacked
into maybe you wouldn't need widespread
fraud you just need it in select places
which is what ted lou said there
uh that you'd be able to switch votes
that that could be done there are
back doors to get into the voting
machines they can be easily hacked that
was ted lue and amy klobuchar
said that we have aging systems uh
kamala they're vulnerable to a
attack she even had a bunch of people in
a room and they had hackers do it right
in front of them
anyway i'm not saying that this last
election was hacked
i'm just saying we should be allowed to
talk about all of these things
and when democrats are on the outs
meaning we have a republican
administration we had orange man for
those four years
they were allowed to say everything they
wanted to say
to make it seem like either the eject
the election
was illegitimate or if he was to be
reelected
that that election would be illegitimate
or hacked or whatever you want to call
it
uh now if we're to say anything you you
would be kicked out of your
country club and potentially kicked out
of
youtube so do with that what you will
i just thought it was important to play
it's like there's
there's something there like so i just
want to know like have you guys fixed
all that stuff
because i know that there's a bunch of
republican bills in a bunch
of states right now that are trying
to fix some of these vulnerabilities as
you guys know we talked about the texas
bill last week and they want things like
paper trails so that if a machine was
hacked there would actually it wouldn't
all be digital there would actually be
paper lit or a paper trail is what it's
called
there would be a long readout like an
actual paper receipt of what happened
but they don't seem to want that and
they don't seem to want cameras
in the rooms where people will be doing
the double counting
and they don't seem to want signature
verification to confirm that the person
who voted
is actually who they say they are so you
know
call me a crazy nut-bad conspiracy
theorist but do these people
want free and fair elections or do they
just want to win elections
which one do you think it is and as i
try to say in all of these things that
doesn't make the republicans perfect
or great or right but they're better
than those people
and i'm not a republican pollster or
on the dole of the republicans but if
you want to slogan
republicans if the republican leadership
if you're watching this show
all you need to do republicans 2024
we're not those guys
and that's what would be the winning
ticket like these people are all crazy
they're all crazy because they say
things and then when they get the power
that they have they reverse everything
that they're saying
so actually perfect segue into the next
uh the next story
so uh senator rand paul got into a
massive blowout
with dr fauci over covid this morning so
this has just happened in the last hour
or so
we're going to show you about a three
minute clip here and originally when i
pulled the clip
i wanted to maybe cut it a little bit
you'll see a flash or two in there
but basically i wanted to give you guys
three minutes of really listen to what
the debate is really listen like i know
it's a little bit technical and i'll
i'll give you the full definition of
what gain of function is after
but really listen to what rand paul is
accusing
dr fauci of and then listen to what dr
fauci says
in a response it's quite extraordinary
and i would just paint one other thing i
don't i don't want to color your
impression of this too much but
especially towards the end
listen to how rand paul is using a lot
of bureaucratic language
instead of giving just a clear answer
did we fund gain a function
uh list you know just listen to how
fauchy is sort of obfuscating
what the answer might be all right take
a look dr falchi
as you are aware it is a crime to lie to
congress
section 1001 of the u.s criminal code
creates a felony and a five-year penalty
for lying to congress
on your last trip to our committee on
may 11th
you stated that the nih has not ever and
does not
now fund gain of function research in
the wuhan institute of virology
and yet gain of function research was
done
entirely in the wuhan institute by dr xi
and was funded by the nih in this paper
dr she credits the nih and lists the
actual number
of the grant that she was given by the
nih
in this paper she took two bat
coronavirus jeans
spike genes and combined them with a
sars-related backbone
to create new viruses that are not found
in nature
these lab created viruses within to
shown to replicate in humans
these experiments combine genetic
information from different coronaviruses
that infect
animals but not humans to create novel
artificial viruses able to infect human
cells
viruses that in nature only infect
animals
were manipulated in the wuhan lab to
gain the function
of infecting humans this research fits
the definition
of the research that the nih said was
subject to the pause in 2014 to 2017
a pause in funding on gain of function
the wuhan lab
used nih funding to construct novel
chimeric
sars-related coronaviruses able to
infect human cells
and laboratory animals this is high risk
research
that creates new potential pandemic
pathogens
potential pandemic pathogens that exist
only in the lab
not in nature this research matches
these are dr ebright's words this
research
matches indeed epitomizes the definition
of gain of function research
done entirely in wuhan for which there
was supposed to be a federal pause
dr fauci knowing that it is a crime to
lie to congress
do you wish to retract your statement of
may 11 where you claimed that the nih
never funded gain of function research
in wuhan
senator paul i have never lied before
the congress
and i do not retract that statement
this paper that you're referring to was
judged by qualified staff up and down
the chain
as not being gained a function
let me finish take an animal virus and
you increase this transability to humans
right you're saying that's not gain a
function yeah that is correct and
and senator paul you do not know what
you are talking about
quite frankly and i want to say that
officially
you do not know what you are talking
about
okay you get one person let's read from
the nih
function is that the the grant that was
funded
as a sub award from eco health to wuhan
created sars kovi 2. that's where you
are getting
let me finish we don't know wait a
minute it didn't come in the lab but all
the evidence is pointing that it came
from the lab
and there will be responsibility for
those who funded the lab
including yourself i totally this
community will allow the witness to
reach i totally resent
the lie that you are now propagating
senator
because if you look at the viruses
that were used in the experiments that
were
given in the annual reports that were
published in the literature
it is molecularly impossible no one's
saying those
it is caused it is molecularly those
virus caused the pandemic what we're
alleging is
that gain of function research was going
on in that lab and nih funded it that is
get away from it it meets your
definition and you are
obfuscating the truth okay so i hope you
guys understand why i showed you the
full clip there because you can sort of
see fauci at the end trying to well we
funded this
and the paper that did this that the
other thing he's given you a lot of
bureaucratic stuff there so
previously he had actually said
that the nih the national institute of
health never
funded gain of function research in the
wuhan lab
rand paul is now saying that is exactly
what you did and we have evidence of it
so i can't sit here and tell you that i
know which
the truth is on that fouchy's saying
well fauci is not exactly saying they
didn't do it anymore right
he's just saying the funding may have
went to something else that was
like sort of ancillarily involved but
not exactly
so let's just pause on that for a second
just let's just be clear about one thing
rand paul is making a very specific
accusation the nih
funded gain of function research
in the woohen lab that's the accusation
fauchi
last time he was under oath and that's
why rand paul worded it the way he did
last time
he was under said that's absolutely
untrue this time he didn't quite exactly
say that
but i thought i'd give you guys a clean
definition of what gain of function is
rand paul explained it i thought quite
well but i thought
if i could just give you the cleanest
possible explanation because this is all
technical stuff
i'm not an expert in this i know you're
not an expert in this but we need to
know
we need to know like some basics about
this right so when you have a
conversation with friends and family
and they're talking about all of this
stuff and lab leaks and everything else
that you have some
ability to communicate some of this
stuff so gain of function research
involves experimentation that aims or is
expected to
and or perhaps actually does increase
the transmissibility
and or virulence of pathogens such
research when conducted by responsible
scientists
usually aims to improve understanding of
disease-causing agents
their interactions with human hosts and
or their potential
to cause pandemics despite these
important potential benefits
uh benefits gain of function research
can pose risks
regarding biosecurity and biosafety so
basically they meddle with
these uh viruses and then the argument
that rand paul's making is then
it can basically jump to humans and then
if that then
leaks out of the lab we have a problem
so on the technical part of this right
like just the legal part
if fauci lied under oath that the nih
was
actually funding gain of function
research at the wuhan lab well then
fauci's in some trouble
so he never fully denied it there and i
think that that is
pretty interesting he's saying oh the
thing that we funded through the grant
that went to the thing and
it's like that's just what perfect
bureaucratic answers are right like
there's always some eight
you know 87 layers from the truth um
i think the bigger issue right now
basically is like how do we figure out
who to trust and how is it
i mean that's what i was thinking when i
was like all right we got to cover this
right because this is a massive blowout
between a senator who i think is a
decent guy fauci
who i i don't think fauci's a horrible
human being i think he's probably in
over his head
i think he's made a lot of mistakes
along the way i don't think this was an
easy job he is the highest paid person
in the federal government and everything
else
but again we're in that information war
where some people are just going to be
like all right
i believe fauci some people are like all
right i believe
rand paul but the simple truth here is
if he lied under oath he's
in a lot of trouble and we should know
right like regardless of what you think
about
covet at this point regardless of what
you think about vaccines and everything
else
we should know if it was our own uh nih
that was funding this stuff right and
then how did it get out
and did he know about it and everything
else and should we be funding
that sort of research as the definition
that i just read describes there are
some benefits to it because we can
figure out
how diseases work and how they jump from
species and all of these things again
i'm not an expert in this and i'm not
pretending to be anything other than i
am
but there's obviously some benefits to
gain a function research
but if then it can create pathogens
that are jumping to humans and then
there aren't perfect
systems to keep them in the lab and they
can leak out and cause like a
i don't know two year shutdown of the
world then we got problems
on our hand uh if you want to know more
about rand paul's feelings
about fouchy about whether the
government was involved in this and
everything else
check out my interview with rand paul
back in march which why don't we link to
that in the description we are a
professional
outfit over here i think we can do that
and uh
you know make some decisions for
yourself but i it's like i don't even
know exactly what to think of that
segment you know i can usually give you
a pretty
a pretty clear opinion on what i think
about things and i'm guessing that you
watching this right now are feeling
something very similar it's like
you know thatchy got very indignant i'm
i'm very offended basically you i'm very
offended by what you're accusing me of
well that
that doesn't mean you didn't do it that
just means you're offended by it
but also rand paul was very clear in
what he did do you want to retract it
now
and and he said no so we shall see we
shall see
uh speaking of covid um okay we know
that the delta variant is spreading okay
i think you guys all know my feelings
on covet at this point actually what you
know more clearly than my feelings
on kovit well first off i believe that
cobit exists i think i probably had
covid a couple weeks ago
i know plenty of people that had covid
and recovered from kovid
i know that a certain amount of people
over the age of 80 with all the
co-morbidities and everything else die
i also know that because of lockdowns
and masks that rates of depression
are up that rates of suicide are up that
rates of alcoholism are up at drug use
and all of these things
that we've destroyed lives and that for
the most of us
and most of you watching this your lives
were far more negatively affected by
government lockdowns
and other mandates and orders
by centralized power and by governments
than they were by
covid itself and even if kovid was
killing half the population
at what point is it no longer the
government's right to tell you you have
to stay in your house
but it is your right as a as a free
individual
on on the planet earth to live as you
see fit and knowing
that there is some risk in the world
right like we all know that there is
some risk
well in any event a lot of people got
vaccinated a lot of people have not got
vaccinated
now they're telling us that if you're
vaccinated it's not as perfect as they
thought
you may need it every six month booster
shot and now they're also
saying that if you get the delta variant
that you can still get covid but perhaps
it will be slightly less sick i would
love to find some more numbers on this
like there everyone's screaming about
the delta variant right now is it
affecting younger people people under 80
are the death rates much higher et
cetera et cetera well australia i'm
going to show you two videos
here from australia because australia
seems to be going into canadian like
draconian measures like really really
crazy stuff so first here is a
australian public health
expert and if you want to see what
fear-mongering is like
true government-issued fear-mongering
take a look at this whilst it is in
human nature
to engage in conversation with others to
be
friendly unfortunately
this is not the time to do that so even
if you run into your next door neighbor
in the shopping center in the coals
while you're at coleslaws or aldi or
any other grocery shop don't start up a
conversation
now is the time for minimizing your
interactions with others
even if you've got a mask do not think
that
affords total protection we want to be
absolutely sure
that as we go about our daily lives we
do not come into contact
with anyone else that would pose a risk
as you go about your daily life you
don't want to come in contact with
anyone else that would cause a risk you
know every moment
of everyone's life they're doing just
that you meet somebody on the street
they might punch you in the face you
walk outside a dog might bite you might
get hit by a car you might get struck by
lightning
the world might explode anything can be
possible there is some
seriously evil orwellian language right
there
do not engage human beings or engage
in conversations do not engage
in conversations why would the
government not want people to engage in
conversations
why would they want us to not talk to
each other at supermarkets as she said
and just limit that
all to online conversation you think
there might be a reason for that perhaps
they could manipulate that conversation
a bit more am i being a complete
conspiracy theorist here i mean that is
scary scary stuff this is also you know
we played a video a couple days ago
um who was the woman i think it was a
woman in new zealand if i'm not mistaken
saying that we are the exclusive source
for truth it was a health minister in
new zealand
we are the exclusive source for truth
the number one source for truth
man i mean this is this is 1984 this is
hunger games this is every dystopian
movie you've ever seen
well now check out this video this is an
australian
news channel talking about new lockdowns
that are coming
and look at the numbers look at the
numbers she's going to put him out you
can listen to her and she's going to put
him on the screen
and i think you'll see what i'm about to
talk about good evening
within hours sydney will be in the group
of much tougher restrictions
the premier clamping down on the
stubborn delta outbreak
with what she's calling a no regrets
policy
and this is why from a record 82 000
tests the state today recorded 111 cases
and tragically the third covert death in
this outbreak
a man aged in his eighties from the
city's south east
across greater sydney retail shops will
now close
a small list of essential stores can
remain open
construction sites across the city shut
down
and from midnight tonight 110 suburbs
across liverpool
fairfield and canterbury bankstown will
be sealed shut
that's nine hundred thousand residents
who can't leave their area
even for work
am i do you tune into this show to go
what does that conspiracy theorist dave
rubin think that
that guy's really gone off the rails
he's quite an alarmist
and he's making people crazy and none of
the stuff that he says makes any sense i
i hope that's not why you're here
but if you watch that and you don't
think something is extremely wrong
i don't know what to make of you 900 000
people basically locked in their house
okay so that's one thing
did you catch the numbers there in
sydney and by the way
i was in sydney two years ago it was one
of the best days of my life
truly it was the last show that i did
with jordan peterson
we did the sydney opera house which is
that iconic building if you've never
seen the sydney opera house go google it
when i'm done with this
it is one of the most gorgeous theaters
on the planet right out there on the
harbor on the on the long boardwalk
the theater i didn't even know until we
got there was a theater not in the round
where you're in a circle but in a square
basically so you have audience on every
side of you behind you in front of you
on the sides it was an
unbelievable show it was our only
matinee show of the day jordan it was a
beautiful day we walked down the
the pier there and hundreds of people
were coming up to us mostly coming up to
him
and it was just such a wonderful
wonderful day i did that show
and then and then i had a family
engagement that was the last show that i
did with jordan sydney was just
wonderful australia was wonderful i love
the people
in australia because they have because
they remind this what i would tell them
on stage
you guys remind me of americans but
you're like more fun you're more
politically incorrect
you know they're they're crocodile
dundee fosters australian for bear you
know like
like there's just like a zest for life
there that seems to be being
squelched by these people so those
numbers that she just referenced
in sydney these are just absolutely
incredible
there were 8 82
000 tests in sydney 82 000 tests
111 came back positive
82 000 tests 111 came back positive
one person died and he's in his 80s
and now sydney is going into complete
lockdown
due to as they said the premier's policy
which is the
no regrets policy um
there might be some regrets that we're
going to continue to ruin people's lives
and we're going to continue to
break down the very fabric of society
and make sure that people don't
talk to each other don't stop and talk
to each other and share
information with other citizens what are
you
some sort of crazed lunatic
this is crazy stuff i mean i look i need
some more context about what's happening
in australia i know i have a big
viewership in australia guys
let me know in the comment section like
what in the world is going on there
82 000 tests 100 come back positive
one guy dies he's in his 80s and you
shut down
a city one of the most spectacular
cities on on this planet
someone explained that to me like just
craziness we're seeing this craziness
in australia we're seeing this craziness
in canada
we're seeing some version of this
craziness come back here in california
los angeles with the mass media by the
way for the record
last night i went to a restaurant it was
david's birthday i took david and his
mom out
for dinner and i walked in without a
mask they came in without a mask
it was fairly obvious that the people at
the restaurant were not thrilled with us
but actually nobody said anything and we
sat down and we had a perfectly fine
dinner so
i know i'm uh i'm a real rebel i'm a
rebel all right let's talk about
socialism because that perhaps is what
this is all about that we are just
watching
governments worldwide centralized power
they are centralizing power against
their free individual citizens that's
what seems to me
to be what the result of the virus of
kovid has done that that's the virus i'm
really worried about i'm not worried
that much about the virus that can get
people sick and of course it can
i am much more worried about the virus
of socialism
and marxism and communism that has is
going to have this elite class
over ruling over everybody else well you
guys all know nicole hannah jones
she is the creator of the 1619 project
which was the new york times
backed project where in essence the
argument of the 1619 project
is that the founding of america is not
really the values of 1776
and individual rights and freedom in the
and the constitution etc etc
it really is that the founding of the
project was 1619
that slavery and racism are the driving
forces behind the history of america now
ironically uh this was done as what was
what we were told was a piece of
historical fact and actual journalism
uh nicole hannah jones has had to
retract a bunch of things from 1619
project and
no serious academic as far as i know is
taking any of this stuff
as fact well now there's some audio
leaking out this is nicole hannah jones
back in 2019 talking about
cuba and socialism and i'm gonna link it
to what's happening of course
in cuba right now and then to some of
our wonderful progressive socialist
politicians of the day
take a listen to this is there are there
candidates right now
or even just places that you think have
a viable and sufficiently
um ambitious integration agenda and if
so what what is it
[Laughter]
that laughs at a lot right yeah i mean
one let me just um
i i'm definitely not an expert on uh
race relations internationally um
and it's also hard to
look at countries that didn't have you
know
large institutions of slavery and
compare them to united states
the answer is probably going to be
surprising
that i'm going to give which is if you
want to see the most
equal uh multi-racial dom
it's not a democracy most equal
multiracial country
in our hemisphere it would be cuba cuba
has the least
inequality between black and white
people
uh uh any place really in the hemisphere
that
i mean the caribbean most of the
caribbean it's it's hard to count
because the white population in a lot of
those countries is very very small their
country's
run by black folks but in places that
are truly
um at least biracial countries cuba
actually has the least inequality
and that's largely due to socialism
which i'm sure no one wants to hear
cuba has the least inequality and that's
largely due to socialism which nobody
wants to hear okay so she's basically
telling
you this is two years ago now she's
telling you that she's a socialist
she almost accidentally calls cuba a
democracy she stops that and her evil
cackle
right at the beginning of something and
also the way these i don't know if that
was an npr guy or it's a national post
thing or something but the way these
interviews the way they talk
do you think that socialism is bad and
like what's up with cuba
and like can you tell me more about that
stuff
like what's wrong with these people can
someone explain to me what what happens
i don't know if it is that you it's the
soy you're like ingesting so much soy
and next thing you know
you're talking like this and you're like
what's going on
and i can't really like think like i'm a
socialist
um anyway so she basically admits she's
a socialist there
what was interesting is she talks about
cuba having the least inequality between
black and white
people so that's good but what she's not
telling you of course is that in a
socialist society
the most inequality is between the
ruling class the ruling class of cuba
right now which is doing pretty good
and the people the people that are out
on the street who are begging for
freedom right and who are running around
with american flags they've got nothing
and the ruling elite have everything
that is what always
happens in a socialist society but she
likes
that they actually like that inequality
because these these socialists these
marxists that we have now they're for
power and she knows
she's gonna be in the ruling elite class
so they're trying to destroy
our system they're trying to destroy our
democracy and the capitalist system and
i'll get to this in just a sec
they're trying to destroy because they
know they will be at the top of the food
chain so when they're pushing socialism
they're post they're pushing socialism
for the
not for me which is what all these giant
corporations are doing right like all
these corporations that have gone woke
they want to still profit off every damn
thing there is trust me i just went to
disneyland it's a disneyland or disney
world here in
uh disneyland yeah went to disneyland
and it's like disneyland
here in in anaheim in california i've
been to the other one i've been to
disney world in florida
but disneyland it's like they go woke as
woke but you know if you go to
disneyland
pretty much all they want is your money
right they want your money they want to
sell you a bunch of plastic
[ __ ] for your kids that they know
they're never going to use
ever again while they're selling you 12
sodas
to make you fat and everything else so
these people are capitalists in their
private life
what are they what is the capitalists in
in the bed what is it in the bed and the
sheets and the something you know what
i'm talking about something in the
sheets and the bed and the
yeah the point is they're [ __ ] all of
us that's the point all right
so i bring this now to aoc because this
wonder woman of
of intellect uh she got into it with
sean spicer actually i'll be on sean
spicer's show on newsmax uh later this
afternoon i'm pretty sure we're going to
talk about just this
well aoc is now selling a whole bunch of
merchandise and she's using the tools of
capitalism
to sell merchandise so sean spicer took
note of that and and he tweeted this
what was the what was the line there he
said that aoc is using capitalism
to push socialism and of course that is
true she is selling
products in our capitalist society while
all day long she pushes
pushes socialism that's exactly what
she's doing well she responded
and she said not sure if you know this
sean
but transactions aren't capitalism
capitalism is a system that prioritizes
profit at all at any and all human
slash environmental cost but for what
it's worth our shop is unionized
doesn't operate for profit and funds
price projects like free tutoring free
programs
and local organizing okay so first off
aoc you simply don't know what
capitalism is
capitalism doesn't prioritize
cost and profit at all expense
capitalism maximizes freedom it
maximizes human choice and competition
so not only do the best products bubble
up and the best human innovation bubble
up
but the best businesses bubble up and
part of that is treating your people
well i mean i talk about this all the
time
i don't treat the guys that are sitting
in this room well uh just out of the
goodness of my heart although i'm a
pretty decent guy
that capitalism allows me to make
decisions as a businessman
to go oh i want to treat my employees
well they'll work harder that'll make a
better product more people will watch
will make more money good for me good
for the company good for the wider world
i hope
capitalism has freed more people from
this the chains of servitude
that socialism and communism and marxism
have brought
so she's using the tools of capitalism
and then what she's saying which is
hilarious
is she saying we don't operate for
profit well i'd like to find out where
the profit ends up going
and it funds project like free tutoring
food programs and local organizing well
all right aoc well then i guess the
government doesn't have to do everything
bernie's brain is about to freaking
explode are you saying aoc
you can sell stuff using the capitalist
system
and then you can take the money from
that stuff
and do what you want with it like tutor
kids and food programs
and local organizing the stuff that you
want to do with it boy
what kind of system gives you the
freedom to do all that where
people can take their own hard-earned
money buy stuff from you
then you can use the money to phone fund
programs you like
you know which system help me here can
one of you guys help me with this one
capitalism but they both said it at the
same time geniuses
you know what you guys can have
guacamole on the chipotle today there
you go because that's
what i'm all about rewarding good work
okay that's what we do around here
anyway aoc is just an
absolutely ridiculous person i did
uh tweet at aoc i feel like i nailed
this one i don't show you my tweets that
often but i felt like i nailed this one
i retweeted her and i said
capitalism is about choice and
competition you dullard
good word many companies are ethical and
generous my own business is included
but glad you finally came out against
the economic system america is based on
now do the constitution and you will
have fulfilled
your destiny and that links us to
the story that i just covered about
nicole hannah jones
and the 1619 project and everything else
as they
undermine capitalism as they undermine
the free market and our ability
to use our money to buy things so that
the people we buy things from can use
their money to do whatever they want
which is exactly what you're doing right
here aoc
as they undermine all that that's not
what this is really about
in terms of just undermining our
economic system it's undermining the
entire
thing because if you think once they
undermine all the economic system that
any
of the rest of our government our three
branches of government and any of the
rest of the way of life that we've all
come to love is going to stand well no
they're they're hacking away
at the foundation right now they're just
hacking at it hacking out and hacking it
and by the way that's why they love
lockdowns too i can actually link all of
the stories
that we did today into one one little uh
conspiratorial bubble if you will
which is that they are hacking away at
everything they love lockdowns
because lockdowns in their minds further
prove that
capitalism doesn't work right and then
we're gonna have to give people ubi we
can't send them to work and they don't
like their jobs in the first place and
you don't pay them enough
and now they're all stuck at home
because there's a scary disease outside
so let's give them all universal
basic income and they'll have just
enough to survive and everything else
it's like they're hacking away at
everything if we are a
house on a beach with some poles
they're hacking away at those poles and
at some point the whole house is going
to come crashing down
i have nothing better to do the same
than save the world and that's what i
intend on doing and i'm going to fight
these people every step of the way
speaking of people that are fighting
these people every step of the way my
friend
and and one of the key guys in my red
pilling adventure
larry elder is running for governor of
california as you may have seen we
posted part one yesterday
larry was actually left off the
role of the 41 candidates that they are
putting on to run against gavin newsom
on an absolutely ridiculous technicality
related to his social security number
and some redactions he is fighting it in
court he should have an
answer as early as tomorrow
i believe that larry elder has all the
right answers um
he i think the interview is just
fantastic so the first part where we
talk about the the legal battle that
he's in just to get on the ballot
we put that up yesterday um we did that
just on a phone because we just wanted
to get it out as soon as possible
uh but part one in essence it's part two
i suppose
of our interview is up right now and of
course the full thing is already up at
rubinreport.locals.com oh and by the way
i am going to freedom fest for the next
three days
so tomorrow which is wednesday we are
doing
our what is normally our thursday q a
but i'm taping it today did you get all
that today tuesday
i'm taping our thursday q a for
wednesday so if you want to submit
questions go right now to
reubenreport.locals.com and then we're
not going to have shows on thursday or
friday but i will be at freedom fest and
i know a bunch of you guys are going to
be there
and maybe i'll do some stuff off my
phone and i know that ion hersey ali is
going to be there and michael shermer
is going to be there and i'm sure a
bunch of other good people so i'm
looking forward
to that um anyway keep fighting guys
right
i got nothing better to do than save the
world see you tomorrow